enchantrex hello hello i am good how are
you hello ryan morrison
oh there's that really long
name on
ultra microscopic
so-called volcano name hey what's up
emily justin
uh black guy m
shiny
allen blind trick
how is it going everyone how is everyone
tonight hope everyone is doing well
i am tired tonight
mr anderson what is up
hope it's chill tonight what is up sane
lily
what is up marcus
yeah i am i'm very excited for tonight's
episode what is up avanesh
dark chin
danny javier
samson sucks
what is going on punisher suraj mcwayne
hello everybody hello hello hello oh
hello back to japan
i don't know how to say your name or
otherwise i would
hello unknown thank you for the love
hello hello
kelly thompson tiffany johnson hello
everybody mr andersen is here so if you
spam
you're gonna get time.jd ultra what is
going on kmg gaming love life wolf wolf
what is going on everyone who's ready
for tonight uh have i watched this
episode suraj no i have not
i have not
i have not seen the last two so i'm
going in
just as excited as everybody else this
time for the live stream i know
it's kind of like bittersweet being like
having watched the other ones before
because i make it's like a different
excitement i'm excited for everybody to
see
what i've seen but at the same time i'm
not like
like really experiencing it with
everybody so it's like
it's different excitement i would say
more excited like going in blind with
everybody so we can all kind of get out
together like to me that's more exciting
so
i'm really really excited for this
really really excited for this
uh when am i going
to the premiere for dark strange
multiverse madness fairness that is a
monday a week from yesterday
so i'm really excited about that um i'll
probably fly in monday that's typically
what i do is i fly in uh the same day
and i fly out the next day
warner brothers wanted me to go to
something for
uh the batman podcast they're doing but
i'm not sure i'm going to be able to go
unfortunately because
that is only a couple days after
so it's in new york
um so i'm like oh man
oh gosh
we got it
a little explosive g feel here hey for a
second what's going on dude
i'll see you in a couple weeks
hey enchantrix that's awesome you guys
are gonna watch it together now cool
cool cool
what is up
everyone can i show my handwriting you
don't want to see it
avenge
monis prime you don't want to see my
handwriting in fact i was i was talking
to a friend
we were texting and she texted me like
some notes that she's like doing for
college
and i'm like i don't even remember the
last time that i like sat there and i
like read things let's see it's all on a
keyboard or on my phone or
or something i do have like a journal
that i keep and i'll write
i'll write in it then but i know no
one's gonna read it so like my
handwriting really is atrocious because
i just don't care because you know
that's just for me so
yeah what are what do we think uh what
do you think is gonna happen in this
episode because
wow is that an ending to
to the previous one i uh
i genuinely loved that
ending part to the last episode it was
really really funny
that cracked me up so
um
i'm excited to see what they got i want
to see if i'm right i think they're in
like this like purgatory type of place
and i think like he might be tested
right now i don't know but we'll see
we'll see
what time is the premiere
i think they're all usually at seven
so although i think moon knight i think
like the premiere was uh
like was that six but that's a show
not a movie um
so
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say it's i have
the invitation let me
let me look just for you i'll give you
the exact
i'll give you the exact one
right here
marvel studios and
invites you and a guest to attend the
world premiere of doctor strange
multiverse madness may 2nd 6 pm
6 p.m there you go
i don't know if you can see it's not
going to focus because i don't have it
on auto focus but
that's it
yeah right mr anderson j lockley tonight
or are we right
all right just checking the stream on my
phone
did the notification go out yes it did
there it is
i mean y'all can hear me so it sounds
like uh
yeah sounds like everything's good i'll
just put that right here just in case i
need to access it for
whatever reason
all right
hit me with your predictions for today
hit me uh hit me with all your
predictions of what we think is going to
happen tonight
got my g fuel
use code cosmic my code is about to be
30 off so if you do enjoy
energy drinks oh
also just give me a quick little teaser
moon knight g fuel
i'm not really like supposed to
advertise that because it's like
completely sold out um
but the new hydration
like moon knight bottles i don't have
any
other moon knight or i don't have any
other hydration bottles on me but
hydration moon night bottle is going to
be coming pretty soon in the meantime i
did get this really cool
shaker
this moon knight shaker
that's pretty cool with my g feel
put that back in there
there we go
uh yeah i see some people asking yes i
am sponsored by g fuel um i was a
consumer before it was sponsored so it's
pretty cool to be sponsored by them i
i drink a lot of drinks guys i drink a
lot energy drinks and you know what
i've been trying to cut back a little
bit which is why the hydration stuff is
actually really good because it gives me
like a good taste
uh
so i'm not just like tasting water
although i do love water you always
gotta stay hydrated
but that's like the g fuel hydration
stuff has electrolytes and stuff and
it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool
uh can i react live on
bra master
indian superhero movie motion poster
you'll not get a strike
can you please watch the video don't
help grow indian super community uh i
have no idea what that is
i am sorry but um
i am going to be for all my my indian
followers out there let me see if i can
get you an exact date i don't think i
can but i can tell you
that
me and ashish
lonnie we are going to be collabing
pretty soon we've been talking a lot and
we're just trying to
kind of lock down our schedules so uh i
hope that will help grow the indian
superhero channel because i know he's
you know he's a very he's a good he's a
big celebrity uh there um
and uh his youtube channel is uh
huge
and he himself is huge and he's a great
guy so uh i can't wait to do that
can't wait to do that
when is it dropping we're we're just
trying to get uh the schedule click
cleared for that so
we'll have to uh see
can you put a countdown for the moon
night episode 10 minutes
uh
i don't know how to
i have a stopwatch ready but i don't
have a countdown so
uh what time is it where i am 12 40 a.m
so
yeah
uh for people who don't know she says
he's really famous in india
um and my indian followers are gonna
correct me if i'm wrong he's just like a
big celebrity there and uh he talks he
gets the interview you know a lot of the
cast members for like a lot of the big
marvel movies and other movies and such
like that and he's on tv and he's got
like twenty
three four million on youtube he's uh
he's just a big guy
uh no i have not seen
uh episode five nick hill kumar you're
asking about the premiere so in the
premiere they just showed us the first
two episodes and they actually sent us
the first four before the premiere so i
had already seen the first two before
the premiere but we just went to the
premiere because it's the event right so
oh thanks gainesburgers uh my best
friend made that for me
like two years ago for like my birthday
or like christmas or
or something like that so
yeah
yeah
28 million subs yeah that's even more
than i thought i think the last time i
checked it was is uh he was a little
lower than that so he's been
he's been freaking growing
uh enchantrix i have discord actually i
don't really
go in it much i started it as like a
like a to make a community for everybody
to be able to talk
um
but then
it just turned into a lot um because it
has a lot of you know people in it
and so then it's like i then you have to
get a staff which i have and uh you know
then it's like oh people get banned and
then people
want to direct message me and tweet at
me and instagram
comment on me and stuff like that and
it's just like a lot of uh
a lot of stuff
um
so i'm not too active on it but you can
it's just the cosmic winter discord you
can uh i think it's
let me take a look here
i think if you go to my
if you go to my channel page
and you go to the about me section
i do have a link for the discord in it i
wonder if it's
right
it is right
so go ahead and you can go there
and and you can chat clancy hello
oh did you wait did you just text me
did i miss it
oh you actually heard that no way that's
so funny well there you go
and go to bed you have school
uh
i just saw something hey billy buck news
what's going on
oh hey uh sat vic it's pretty cool that
i'm the first superhero chinese south
there's a lot out there so i'm uh i'm
honored that i was the first one
cute sleepy kitty on the chair what's
their name so
if i move does it get does it focus more
no this is rocket and yes i named her
after rocket raccoon uh i have another
one and she is
probably probably just wandering around
somewhere and her name is kyrie and
she's named after
uh kingdom hearts character
so
yeah thanks for super chat appreciate it
oh hey dev dang follow me since 20k
appreciate that
that's a long time
long long day what's up brother jones
what's going on
bruce wayne you are batman well don't
tell everybody come on
i i saw you enchanted tricks don't worry
i gotcha
hey sebastian member neck what's going
on was it on his head caster bets bet
best bets now
i don't think it was on his head i
i i really don't think it was on his
head that's that's just me
um
but yeah i i i think you should cast
your bets now i think we should take a
little we can't do pull on here uh we
probably can't i just don't know how
live
uh but you know we can't let's uh
let's do like a little let's do kind of
a poll here and uh
oh here's the chat
and let's see let's see let's see let's
see
what are we thinking
ah mr anderson i saw you delete her
thing and i was wondering why but no
worries
no worries
i think she knows we mean her no harm
she's in here every time she's an
awesome awesome fan
hey victor rodriguez
oh man you know i don't i don't think so
but they are coming out with hydration
uh
bottles i always like how do i forget
the name bottles uh
pretty soon so that's pretty cool um i
think there's like
i don't know if there's a mix up or
like
they just
sold out super fast but
yeah um
i wish i had better more interesting i
know eventually yes they will restock i
don't know when i don't know how long
which is you know
what i wish i could tell you so
so yeah hey sue
how's it going
i saw something
[Music]
yeah mr anderson i actually don't know
how to undo it either
i i've i've like noticed that i've never
i i've never like
i don't know how to
un-delete a comment
but yeah enchantrex if you're still
watching which i believe you are can you
comment again so i can
go to your channel and click on your
name thanks
uh
jsp our most
anticipated
multiverse of madness cameo
probably john krasinski is mr fantastic
it's been talked about for so long
at this point in time you're always like
is it true is it not true
um i okay and check this out i firmly
believe this we have three minutes left
we have three minutes left i
i firmly believe that
there is misinformation out there on
purpose to confuse people because i've
heard very conflicting reports
and i know like the people spreading
them and i'm like i know these are
credible people so i'm pretty sure
because like i mentioned
marvel was pretty strict about
multiverse of madness
they
they asked me to take one video down top
where i went over like a crap ton of
rumors
um
you know and they're like hey let's not
you know we don't want anything really
spoiled we want this to be a big movie
we want a lot of surprises in it so i've
you know i've kind of just been like
chilling right no major plot lakes or
anything like that
so i know they've been doing their best
i know they've been doing their absolute
best to keep things a secret
and with that
i've seen people say one thing and other
people say other thing and they're like
all these people are credible people and
i'm like you're doing this i know you're
doing this on purpose to like
to have people surprised so i actually
believe that so i'm actually very
curious to see who all the cameos are i
really am
i really am uh yes for those asking yes
i was invited to the doctor strange
premiere it is monday i will be there i
will do my best to take pictures and
videos
and uh i will put it
on my instagram
uh
like
if you're not following my instagram and
stuff i was just trying to think how do
i
i think it's in the description it's in
the description of this i believe it
works yes i have a cause of what
instagram but my personal instagram is
pretty much where i post
all the stuff and stupid stuff as well
like memes and crap like that so
if you're curious go ahead follow
i'll post most of the stuff there
uh
do i
do i think we want to see tom cruise's
uh iron man yes or no yeah yes uh i do
jd
um
do i think we will ah man you know i've
heard reports that says
you know no hey ritwik what's going on
what's going on
uh where do i rake no where no way home
uh among mcu spiderman movies
uh the top
amir king yeah the the top like
totally on the top
doggy style what a name nice how's it
going doing well uh apparently it's out
let's take a look
the shadow catcher love the channel all
the way here in samoa hey
what is going on
thank you so much i appreciate the
support
um
i'm having a hard time finding my
browser here there we go
disney plus
all right i'm assuming it's out because
it is 12.50 and that's how they do it we
know how they do it
asylum oh
are they gonna all right this is gonna
be like a full dive into this all right
well here we go we're gonna start this
and five
four
three
two
one oh i need to start the timer
okay
hey
jordan
childers what's going on childers
childers
sorry if we can't pronounce that right
see ya for a second see you hunter but
thank you for that uh super chat jordan
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go
oh and changes you got timed out i know
mr anderson didn't mean to do that
here hold on let me get rid of the timer
for a second i want to see something
it's just doing the recap right now
all right here we go it's starting
why don't i
there it is
cool
all right i have everything set up let's
watch some freaking moon night
oh
a boy is yelling help we're gonna get
like a flashback scene here aren't we
oh
whoa
he wasn't
he wasn't that messed up before
he looks beat up
starting imaginary fights
i took the bus you're a doctor and you
took the bus
you were with a rhinoceros a
hippopotamus
sensor nonsense
uh i kind of know quarter crew i've seen
a few other stuff
i'm
this can't be real he can't just really
be mentally ill it can't all be made up
oh he turned it on him turned it on him
hippopotamus
and
jake
okay
oh tell me about the little boy
oh this is gonna be intense
no dang
these meds are amazing
uh do i beef with other youtubers no
they're in like the purgatory place like
i thought it was
this is like a certain place they go
she likes her lips
field of reads
of the duet the egyptian got underworld
wow
yep
just guiding us through this i knew it
i freaking knew it
thank you omar okay gamer
and afterlife interesting
huh
did sister play for black panther
interesting
psych ward's a first for me
we're insane
that's the imagination
oh
[Music]
that's
that's so cool
aru
feel the reads
mm-hmm
you're gonna shove them up
oh she has to take their hearts
yeah
yeah
well they're they're dead
she's gonna put him on the scales
on the scales of justice
and if not ahmet eat your heart
oh well they changed that a little bit
them's the rules
oh i wonder if there's anybody
i was trying to see if you could see
anybody down there
i don't know
interesting
is it because you're missing a heart
where's jake
because there's
oh dang
oh we're about to
see some stuff i think
marcus jake from state farm
that's insanely cool
that's insanely cool
what's going on ricky
but she's any
all right get the other sarcophagus oh
mine too
this is it
is he gonna open the other no
that's where they reversed well not
really reverse time
yeah mark wasn't there for that
that's so cool hey what's up john paul
apple
cheers back to the philippines oh what's
this
oh
steven has the same coin
it's jake
no that's jake i just want you to
introduce him come on
jake from state farm
oh
are these actual people
there's a oh oh oh what's that
oh there people he's killed
are they really people he's killed
they're people he's killed they have to
be
all of them dang
oh i knew it
travelers of the night
dag
hey random player 34
please tell me it's freaking jake
oh it's the boy
it's a boy that jake
filled with the people you've killed
dang
oh it's getting deep
he locked him out
young mark
brother
oh
oh this is really gonna die
latest gate is
oh
man
i'm starting to think that maybe jake
won't appear
oh look at that
from the movie
interesting
oh you're so dead
that sucks
oh a bird
yeah you're right marcus it is
huh let's see what you did there antonio
knight with a k
lads
dr grant is uh
from the movie tomb busters or something
that they you know that they showed last
time
so it's how mark created
stephen grant it was dr stephen grant
well we already know his brother's gonna
die we already already know that
well that's sad
you know it's a memory why are you
trying to
it's just a memory of something that
happened clearly
yo ethiopia
love back
oh what's going on here
is it locked oh no it's not locked
uh is this the
like the wake
the viewing because i see a picture of
his brother
hey congrats f youtube congrats
so that's the father and the mother
there
oh no she's not handling it weird or
she's not handling it well
obviously it would be weird
and there's a young marky boy
she's gonna hate him
punch her in the face
elias
yeah so his mom's just gonna hate him
for the rest of his life
got it
oh that is actor i thought it was
is it
i think it is
and now the moms are drunk
oh gosh
good don't take that crap
no
no it's not the edge i thought it was
oh wait
where are they oh this is gonna be it
this is gonna be egypt
this is gonna be
this is going to be where he died
and became moon knight
well where he assassinated no i guess he
might not have
assassinated people yet
bushmen
yep there's or here's origen
oh foolie layla's dead
dang
i died
can't you
happen to him
oh
oh this is gonna be cool
oh there it is look there's kanchi
statue
and he's in front of him
and
oh he can kill himself
oh he didn't actually fully die
if god can't you sweet
my vengeance
for gotham
oh i feel it fractured broken
oh is that way chosen
oh
he like he did he like prayed on him
because his mind was like damaged
the travelers of the night
he's been manipulating you from the
start wow
what killer
i called it
yes
oh
ah
sweet
baboons
oh that's freaking
hero
well
i like it
i knew she was gonna help
cyrus isn't going to like this
oh
of cyrus's gate
that's pretty freaking cool
i'm confused can she not
can she bring the back right now
day
do
oh jeez
now
jeez
and his nose is fixed now oh gosh
that's exhausting
that's exhausting
huh
hey jay what's going on
she didn't get slapped by will smith
that's hilarious
narrow
hello
this is my room
oh this is where it's
this is where he created him
tomb busters stephen grant oh he's gonna
he's gonna learn that he's not real
he's gonna learn that he's made up
do
frick
dang
see a shadow
dang
oh gosh there's so much he's hitting him
with
hahahahaha
little haircut a little stash there
ned flanders oh my gosh
that's hilarious
ned flynn that's so funny simpsons
he really does look like
flanders
who the heck is his mother then
he is the knockoff
bran ned flanders
oh he's crying
he knows i know she's dead who the heck
is he gonna talk to who's he been
calling
my mom is that he knows it
so who's he been talking to
uh
that's what it is
i mean she hated him from the freaking
start
that would be tough
dang
that's rough
ah that's rough
jeez
no and here comes steven or jake
steven
dang
i love how it's bloody hell
who's he talking to
please ask him who you're talking to
oh it just happened
yeah for real
oscar is amazing
oh did they figure it out
i love how steven knows it all it's so
funny
so what do they do now
they look kind of balanced to me
oh
bit
so
they're made out of sand it's like what
are you gonna do
oh he's turning the vote
so can they go back inside and try to
finish balancing them
oh
haha sandman them see you
and then jake lockley comes busting
i've got this
yes do it stephen
nice
six
oh
beat that sand
wow
oh
oh does he get
does he get
like frozen
no
no
not stephen take mark instead
no
oh that's a bummer
oh
that's so sad
oh no
oh no
steven doesn't make it
oh no
oh my gosh
oh that's terrible
that is not what i wanted to see happen
oof
no
dang
oh
no
not stephen he was the best of us
i'm checking if there's a post credit
oh
is it
nope just a marvel studios logo
and then
looks like a manner in chinese
yeah
how
disappointing
oh
man i'm so sad no go back i don't want
to watch the eternals right now please
take me back to
i'll watch the eternals later again
oh
no
how
just
what a huge
bummer
oh what a huge bummer
all right
well that sucks
but a good episode
wow
[Music]
oh
steven is just what a wow i'm tiny teary
ed because like
wow
wow
ah you're right marcus stephen and juana
might be best friends the freaking
traumatized people of the freaking mcu
here
uh hey i like what you did there sue
sue i have some korean questions for you
i need to talk to you outside of youtube
somehow
we'll figure it out one day my email is
in the about me section if you want to
email me i'm about to go to korea soon
because the quarantine
uh lifted
oh yeah we didn't see jake
no jake
i'm wondering if we actually will see
jake or if that's just going to be like
we put that
other sarcophagus in there as like a
note to the comics like you guys know
jake's there but like
maybe he's not maybe like in the mcu
he's not there
maybe he's just gonna be like an easter
egg and he's never actually gonna show
up
oh
wow
wow i uh
i i did not think it was gonna go that
way i didn't i didn't think we were
gonna lose steven
and i don't think he's gone obviously
like
uh
so can you put your instagram tag
because and let like i don't get dms
unless i'm actually following somebody
yeah tony totally like i like i totally
i totally understand that's a great
point thanks for super chat steven isn't
real so it makes sense he had to
sacrifice himself to balance the scales
right
and it's you know it's part of dealing
with this trauma with this mental
illness it's you know it's really
it's it's deep like you know let's let's
be honest like this is pretty deep like
this is definitely more mature
show
on like a lot of different levels like
this this is like really
really deep
i know the ned flanders joke for the
from the simpsons that was classic that
was so good yes i can hear you
the dead flanders joke
that was really good
i loved i was like oh my gosh he does he
looks exactly like flanders
i
personally
really
no i did
i liked it but for those of you who
don't know i have a degree in psychology
and went to graduate school as well
for it for a bit
so i like stuff like this yes
i am saying
noriga uh ancestral plane for black
panther yes
that's what i said as they said that i
was like ah black panther
sean thanks for super chat buddy i know
i'm sad too oh
yeah see i see a lot of people like best
episode yet blah blah blah blah
loved it bradley what's up man
uh what's going on with dr harris at all
imagination i'm confused i think it's
like people have self-coping mechanisms
i truly believe that they died
and i i truly believe that they died
and um
hold on let me make it so they can hear
chris because i don't think they can
hear chris what did i just do
oh no
i truly believe they're dead
and
i think it's just self coping right as
they they have to go through all this
and
pass through all this stuff i think it's
just when you realize
right when it's part of it you really
it's how he's able to recall
basically
right it's that this is how he's able to
bring this is how he comes to terms with
his mom dying and then he and he relives
it right this is how he comes to term
with other things he relives it he goes
through it all right all right like i
need therapy to even understand what's
going on in my life yeah and that's what
uh towerette said it was like
i've never seen the psych ward before
but sure we can roll with this like yeah
what's up malek what's going on yeah
right it's exactly what i thought it was
it was like in between like
it was it was in between the field of
reads and turning into a statue or
whatever right it says it was purgatory
like i talked about my breakdown last
time i yeah i i figured that's what it
was that's what we talked about last
time
chris and i are
on the money on the money you know what
i'm not gonna bring on the money for the
next episode yeah i know what's up billy
buck news thanks for hanging out
people were asking and saying you know
okay so like
what and i was like honestly this is
what i do and warren might have an idea
this is what i do for a living every
single day but this could go wherever
they want it to they have literally set
us up with and i will say it
a premium package
for the alley premium package they are
going to slam dunk this already
relatively flawless series home in
episode six and and it's all there for
them to take i am so excited
yeah um
a lot of people complaining about not
seeing jake
i don't think we will
i don't think there's time unless it's
like a very end like hey jake's here too
yeah well here's actually a super chat
about it anime dimension thanks for the
super chat what about third personality
i thought the scales had to be balanced
he's supposed to be
whole all three personalities i think
this is just an easter egg as sad is it
as sad as it is i think jake was just an
easter egg i think they're going hey you
know in the comics of the high s3
yeah we kind of hit that at that but
you're not going to see him because we
gotta
shove it into six episodes like
multi-level uh platform video games
where there's like characters to unlock
in their silhouettes like jake's still a
silhouette right yeah
maybe you can unlock he's like a bonus
after you beat the boss
he'll just show up right
to him
this episode left me with more questions
and answers supposed to yeah that's why
and that's why it's an alley-oop you
know yeah it chucked us up there and now
we're about to get slammed down yeah
this episode of more depth to it you
can't call it best but it was character
progression more
yeah i think people are going to have
very mixed feelings about this one i for
one really enjoyed this one i
i loved it
i had a lot of fun i like deep
intricate things and i also like not
knowing what's happening
uh that part's pretty cool to me yeah
aiden harrington thank you for that
super chat what are my theories for how
the finale episode would turn out got a
feeling country will be bought into the
main mc reality somehow with ahmed yeah
i would actually really love to see like
arthur fights harrow and ahmed fights
khan shu like wouldn't that be cool
wouldn't a godly fight be cool yeah have
we really seen
with the exception of like thor have we
really seen like a god fight like we've
seen the celestials they haven't fought
each other
right hey we saw a living tribunal and
multiverse
i can't
talk about it why did they show that
my assumption and you can tell me what
you think about this since we brought it
up real quick
my assumption is
it's going to be a huge hint to the
character and that is all we're going to
see of him yeah i don't i actually
multiverse yeah and it's going to be
like oh look the living tribunal is
watching and maybe they'll do it a few
times like as they're doing those cool
right he's just watching in the
background he's just going to be in the
background throughout the whole movie
just watching the whole thing and then
maybe that'll be a post-credits scene or
they'll introduce that later on i don't
think he's going to get involved you
were talking about that today in the
video you did um yeah i did watch it um
and uh
it makes a lot of sense like
his involvement so it makes sense to
have him in the background yeah i think
i think
the connection with mordo with the staff
i think he might kind of be like all
right mordo like
maybe he talked to
the variant more than like all right
we're gonna counsel you're gonna guard
the multiverse do not call me
unless
you might want to watch what's going on
here
what's happening because i'm trying to
get judgment but there's this witch
that's like not supposed to exist
everybody show some love for zochi gomez
on instagram and twitter please
so she is my friend
so she so she's getting bullied and it
sucks and she's my friend yeah she's
like the coolest she's so nice and she
guys chatted with us for like 20 minutes
at the moon night yeah literally like
they were trying to pull her away and
she was just sitting there chatting with
us yeah like people were trying to pull
us away too and she was like no no like
we're talking i was like yeah uh i've
met her many times we've chatted many
times show her some love
she's young too guys like very brave
very brave people are yelling at her
like she's a 30 something year old adult
when she's like 16 years old
okay back to
moonlight marvel's killing us right now
and this time next week warren and i
know they're killing mark and steven is
what they're killing mark and stephen
this time next week we'll be coming back
home from doctor strange and then trying
to process the finale for this and it's
gonna be
we might have mush for brains dude i'm
already out of most of her brains
we're going to be in the psych ward
yelling at each other maybe we are now
maybe we're the same person now
wait are we the same person i'm gonna be
chat is there a cosmic culture because
that sounds like an altar that sounds
like a made-up thing warren and me
are the same people oh my gosh is this
someone tell me if it's real someone
tell me if there really are two
different channels every day i wake up
right oh gosh um but we do need to
address this
there's no way it's not real
they're trying really hard to drag us
along
and be like is he actually just making
all this up is he actually in a sarc
ward is it not real and i hope they
don't really carry that on to the end
yeah the end needs to be a fight like a
god fight it needs to be like yeah okay
this is all real but i my point is i
don't feel like it can
be oh yeah that was all fake and made up
and this is all irrelevant right like
what do you think about that as far as
that would be a really social awareness
of the the multi-personality disorder
and everything and they're really
dragging it on which is really cool and
interesting and adds this other element
in the background i have a really
important question first
what is the funko pop above spider-man
the spider-man helmet in your background
is that magneto
this one yeah that is knuckles the
echidna
and that's dwight schrute and this is
steve irwin got him today nice
okay i was like magneto
um
oh i did buy it and this is exciting i'm
so pumped this is like i haven't been
this excited since like the finale of
one division or loki probably this is
this is marvel disney plus just doing
what marvel disney plus do yo cody you
make a good point though if jake is an
easter egg then who killed those guys
that neither mark or stephen killed yeah
it was totally jake
yeah jake's coming
yeah did we make up a super hot woman
probably yeah
um
wait but like i
totally yeah he totally killed them but
like oh there's definitely a third
person yeah but i don't think we're
gonna see him i really don't i really
don't unite is left for the future of
the mcu they can't give us all of the
baskets will will they save jake for a
post credit like a funny post-credits
scene that could make sense right like
him like finally breaking the tomb and
like i'm in charge now walk away right
yeah something that's all you get
he has like a name tag says hello my
name is jake yeah i really hope that
that's not
the case
no i don't know i feel like we're
definitely getting a post-credit scene
that's going to be teasing the future of
moon night right so everybody wants to
know what's the post-credits scene going
to be if we get one i don't think it's
going to be
kang i don't think it's going to be
something like that as much as i would
love to see kang as an avatar or one of
kang's variants as an avatar for
somebody and a pharaoh which would just
be which he was it was rama tut right
right so it would fit in beautifully
i don't think we'll get a post credit
scene like that because it's a disney
plus series we have to keep our
expectations to what they've been so far
and that's true to the character yeah
the only post credit scene we get will
be setting up the future of moon night
so that would be jake right
it would be i would assume but yeah
i don't
crazy crazy i just don't i don't think
it's gonna connect that much
but uh real quick haiti appreciate super
chat and i appreciate you actually
commenting this
as someone who suffers from mental
health this episode hit deep felt so raw
i appreciate marvel tackling stuff like
trauma and the after effects yeah and
that's you know people are asking what
uh
you know what's the deal with
dr haro
what's that whole thing about it's
coping i think i think that's just how
the my i think you know you have to
right it's in his mind right we do we do
things in our mind we come up with
scenarios and we put ourselves in like
uh
like imaginary situations right uh
it just happens a lot
you know
i meant war a lot in my mind
and and it's just how you deal with some
things and i think that's
cool to tackle like i said i think
people are going to heart's attacking
very it is
and it's cool to hear like you said from
the people who actually uh has
experience with this because we're all
kind of looking at it through ignorant
eyes
yeah like we don't know how accurate
this really could be so somebody who
maybe struggles with this sharing their
thoughts on it is really really cool and
a cool addition to the community so yeah
thank you oh my gosh
well first of all let me go back really
quick and say thank you hayden i really
appreciate that but i have a famous
deputy 1024 in my chat i did too he was
telling me that he thought that this was
pirates of the caribbean johnny's locker
oh jake is a secret identity because
moon knight wants to keep it under
raps
you honestly i could have read that and
i would have told you that that was it
right
that jokes i want to start the bring
stephen back hashtag but let's not
because people will know
something happened
online and we don't want to spoil things
not yet wait maybe like three did yeah
bun chan hey thanks for the is that
krillin i can't tell that it looks like
krillin
uh conscious mark unconscious jake and
subconscious stephen ooh i like that
jacob's unconscious mind which is why he
has no memories
for introspection
i like it i actually really like that a
lot
thanks for that hey ismail back with
another one how's it going
so if the scales are balanced what
happens now well
he went to heaven they're apparently
yeah well
yes he went to the field of reads but
now i'm confused because they were
heading for the gates of osiris
right so he's going to get a chance to
turn around and he is or lyla's going to
free count you and conscious going to
come save him something like that
because they sent a message to lila
right and tower i was like yeah i'll do
that that's easy
did they
yeah she said they were on the boat and
he said you need to tell allah to free
kanchu and she said are you sure you
want to go back to kanchu it seems like
you're happier without him and they said
do it
let's yeah let's go over that because
that's a big thing
yeah so
she going free conscious the next
episode is going to start with lila
where we left her off she's going to go
free conscious somehow don't ask me if
layla freeze kanchu
then yeah he brings him back yeah kanchu
gonna go find them
them gonna be
or him i guess steven's gone he's gonna
be like will you join me again and he's
gonna be like i hate you but yes but yes
i am going to go back and then
big fight gods let's do it yeah
and we're never going to probably until
unless they like tease the whole coping
let's say uh asylum thing again we're
probably never going to visit that again
unless they like tease it and keep it
kind of as they're going well let me ask
this question now as i scan through
where this exact part was because i
can't seem to find it now
let me ask let me ask the chat now yeah
but there's like it cuts back and forth
between the asylum so i gotta find the
exact part
if
i wanna know how everyone feels
hey
baracus thompson welcome to the cosmic
fam thank you so much for becoming a
member super appreciate
um
i don't want to say it
because i don't want like people to be
members just because of this but i have
surprises coming for some members pretty
soon um
but like only for like 30 members so
like i don't want it to like
get too much um
we got like four more spots
yeah i want to know how
the chat would feel
if it actually was all on his head what
what if it ends and it's like yeah you
were
mentally ill this is in your head the
entire time
i wouldn't like what if it just ends
with him just like
in the asylum
how would we feel i want to know i
genuinely want to know let me know in
the chat let's let's let's talk about it
uh and then tahin thanks for those super
chat i love the fact that anakin and
stephen are going to be just the
characters who made sand yeah they are
gets everywhere
deputy i've rode the mummy before death
is only the beginning
all right while everybody is letting me
know if it's in your if it's in his head
or not i'm continuing to search for
i think i found it wait is this that
hey haiti welcome to the cosmic fam
thanks for becoming a member and again
super appreciate you sharing your
comment before
uh israel thanks for the super chat so
stephen had to die in order for mike to
be mentally stable now
maybe i don't think steven's gone
there's no way he's gone
you if this character moves on forward
into the mcu which if if it does end up
being all fake he might not this might
just be a one-off series and that's the
end of it no but if he does
there will be no success for moon knight
if stephen is not there oh yeah stephen
is in that character if we're talking
money if we're talking character
satisfaction for us yeah i was gonna say
i just think it's out of space nobody
nobody will connect with moon knight if
stephen isn't there no
steven's the best part
stephen's awesome
we love stephen we're we're uh we're as
uh steven is part of the cosmic fam an
honorary cosmic fan hey it's ahead and
welcome to the cosmic fam i knew i
shouldn't have said it but i appreciate
everyone becoming a member and yeah i'm
gonna get some get some stuff
uh pretty soon here well i'm working
with will to maybe create some you know
more hoodies what um
what's that about uh
overplayed ending i literally discourage
students forever using that as an ending
like when it's all
in their head mr anderson's that we're
talking about i know i i i hate those
like what's uh oh gosh i'm not gonna be
able to remember the movie it's on the
tip of my tongue
oh no no no no no no
yeah everybody on my side is saying that
if it was just all fake they would be
pissed
yeah it's like inception at the very end
when he like spins the thing and it's
like if it falls down he's in reality
but if it keeps spinning he's still in a
dream and if they just show it keep
spinning it looks like it's going to
slow down but they don't actually show a
stopping that's annoying yeah i don't
like that that's annoying just as a way
to do movies i'm not a show right no me
neither shutter island that's why i went
to leonardo shutter island yes this is
very much shutter island like
did they make him crazy and were they
you know were they evil and they they
like tricked him or was he actually
crazy he made up the whole entire thing
uh i have a take that says steven better
stay dead marvel has no stakes anymore
if they bring him back they have to kill
him i feel well he's not a real person i
guess that's the thing is mark could
just summon him back to life and it
wouldn't even be that cheap mark could
just recreate it yeah
yeah i mean what it wouldn't really be
that difficult but i think he's if they
don't like physically bring him back
like another you know person because
he's gonna go back to earth plane where
there aren't going to be two of them
right i think he's just going to look in
the mirror and be like oh
latest gate is
right we'll see uh hold on real quick
he rich thomas uh go to the five minute
mark it's jake's accent i'll take a look
at that in just a second uh anime
dimension thanks for another super chat
as per comic just like how spiderman
will always have personal problems
midnight will have his personalities yes
i totally agree okay um i will pause on
eric on yours
you rich i'm sorry sorry i've i
pronounce names just horribly um it's
because i speak like a couple different
languages so i never know how to say it
like
it's where it makes it really hard it
makes it hard to like
i also do how do i put right because
like a lot of times i'll say things like
i'll pronounce like in spanish
all right so hold on
okay okay
let's sarah what's going on here
fear spreading in the upper world okay
let's take a look here
this is evil yes it is evil it's on it
okay here it is
even if i could see you back up there
so that's how it's going to start next
wait hold on let me finish the scene
oh you know what
uh she says she says his gate is the
only gate path i'm wondering if that's
like for her
like for her
opened up at the end
yeah but if she has to go tell layla i'm
wondering if like
yeah i'm not sure because if she she's
the goddess that helps people to the
other world right she navigates
themselves that's where she's also gone
at the end when they were fighting the
bad guys maybe she's the one that goes
through the gate right who knows but
regardless layla is gonna know
that they need right and that's how it's
gonna yeah yeah all right now let me go
to the five minute mark and let me hear
jake's accent
thank you i feel
really great
i mean they always pay you a lot of
money that that is jake's accent wow
totally you were right wow thank you so
much for that thanks for putting that up
at the five minute mark when he's
talking to dr harrow and when he's
bandaged up i noticed that that's
different
that's jake it actually is wow why are
they addressing this more obviously
a question about
why's he got a bandage why is he looked
yeah why is he acting different that's a
good point as well so yeah i think
jake's there i think we're gonna see
jake obviously and it's gonna be a lot
of fun yeah for sure episode six might
need to be a little longer
i it's gonna have to be a finale yeah
this one wasn't a filler episode
like it wasn't a pointless episode i
don't think so it had a lot of character
development it built so much for the
final episode to carry it's gonna be
it's gonna be a big ask but it's gonna
be a huge payout yeah cameron wood
thanks for super chat steven is dead
mark and steven are the same agreed yes
totally he had to die for the scales the
balance stephen can finally accept his
trauma that's what i think it's about
it's about acceptance
it's about dealing with trauma that's
this they said they were going to tackle
mental illness in the show and they are
and quite beautifully might have
uh
brooks thompson oh another super chat
after became a member you're too kind
what is the difference between spirit of
vengeance
and gods vengeance they're talking about
vengeance a lot um i think it's just a
title kind of a con yeah it's a
conscious thing
in all honesty yeah i hate to give you
such a you know an answer like that
yeah can we talk about
how
gorgeous
the origin scene was and how just like
with the thor 11 thunder trailer it was
an exact shot from the origin oh yeah it
was pretty great that was the statue and
everything marvel has done marvel has
gone
into a comic accurate
like
in each project giving you something
like super comic accurate which has been
pretty freaking sweet absolute crushing
uh brian much gaming so sorry let me get
to that i i'm glad i glanced over at
that
uh let me refresh the super chats here i
did not mean to miss your super chat but
i got you
the little girl the first episode
predicted stephen state being rejected
from the field of reads yeah that's uh
isn't that interesting i talked about
that a little bit last episode uh no no
i i think i typed on the live chat
there's there's the um
theory that stephen or mark or whoever
you want to call it was actually dead
the entire time
and and that's why that little girl was
like did it hurt being rejected he's
like well i'm not dead and it's like oh
wait maybe you are
i don't think
mark has been dead the entire time but
steven obviously hasn't been
well it's hard to you can't really say
steven hasn't been really at a job he
had like
all this other stuff you know what i
mean like
you can't really say stephen wasn't real
he was
yeah he's the same person different
personality but the dude had a job
right the dude had a life
i mean
yeah i mean
yeah okay i got a super chat from the
moon night thank you so much i want to
think that mark will eventually let jake
out one guy said this earlier and how
jake's personalities were in a twine
with how his mother was angry violent
mark could have jake come out and help i
i really hope
um the only thing i'm thinking is that
he's not aware of jake
that's the only problem
jake is totally his third personality
and
um
hey rich smith at that five minute mark
you you can see
you you can hear
jake
you can hear jake's personality you
you really can which is pretty crazy so
i would like to think that he's going to
come out but but i don't think mark
knows about him
so
uh devonte what sorry about it i was
excited i've got for you the craziest
fan theory that i've just created in my
mind that 100 isn't true well hold on
for two seconds devante thank you for
that super chat
has anyone considered if the gods will
owe mark
a boon so he'd be able to bring steven
back or we'll stephen be able to come
back via country power i i think he's
just gonna be there
i
i don't see how you get rid of steven
and we have to remember that steven is
not a physical person he is a
personality and identity inside of
mark's mind so i think
i honestly think mark is going to have
the like ability to bring it back free
will
so
let's just get my thoughts on all right
chris hit us with your
incorrect theory okay
wrong
mark
steven
and jake
all
are in despair and dying conscious
abandoned them and they become an avatar
for the living tribunal representing all
three of his faces his personalities and
his judgment he moves on to become a
different avatar
that was it confirmed
you heard it here first
and moonlight is just done they're done
with the moon it was a one-off but they
want to keep the characters so that's
where you get the three phases of the
living tribunal that's funny i just feel
like oh yeah jake was here too we need a
third i like your thinking
you just gotta connect dots yeah what's
up that one sock nugget another member
in the chat that's so funny that's i
like it i like where your head's at i
like your head's that other three heads
but no way but no possible way ritwik
says today was a heavy the trauma he
went through that yeah it takes a toll
on your mind yeah it was a really cool
representation of that 100
yeah i i really like this episode i
people
i
i don't know how it's split but i do
know
some people do tend
to not like character development
episodes where
plot necessarily doesn't move forward so
much
that what do they call them filler
episodes uh yeah yeah yeah yeah we got a
few of them i don't think
loki's still my favorite i say a bunch
of people have been asking me to chat
loki or moon knight because i have you
know
announced loki is my favorite it's still
my favorite by far
steve irwin
you gotta be there jd ultra hey guys
to me there's a lot of balls in the air
a lot of unknown answer questions that i
don't think you're going to be able to
wrap it up one episode do you think
i would like to see a nice end yeah
um that's why i don't think
jake like introducing jake would be a
lot for the finale um and we don't want
the finale
as much as i did actually truly love
this episode i don't want the finale to
be like this at all it needs to be
it needs to be
mark and stephen come you know come back
somehow against harrow and then i i want
to see kanchu fight ahmet and maybe some
other guys i need to see like arthur
fighting mark while
conscious fighting
ahmet
and then other gods show up
do you think some gods will be released
do you think that wall of gods is gonna
be shattered and they're all gonna get
out and
some crazy gore stuff's gonna start
happening that's what i thought might
happen like maybe those gods and the
statues are gonna be released somehow
uh i don't think he's gonna connect to
thor love and thunder
just because like the writers and the
directors i don't think any of this is
gonna directly connect but you and me
you know doing what we do best we're
just no it would totally make sense
and that's the problem it's just like
one division like the whole everybody
make a big meme about it you know the
whole mephisto thing and i get it right
it's hilarious yeah
but mark kind of let us on
oh for sure like for sure it was
there the connecting dots were there
just like they're here now for you know
oh this could make sense with doctor
strange if this could make sense with
thor 11 thunder and gore the god butcher
and look at all these gods they're
introducing and like it's there and
marvel's just really teasing us with all
of phase four which is going to make the
big reveal of whatever we're really
doing here
so much better and i know a lot of
people are getting a little impatient
because we have these high expectations
for marvel but i think they're on to
something pretty pretty great
oh i do too i
fully trust kevin feige i think he knows
what he's doing exactly as
yeah no for sure
um no i wouldn't expect miles morales a
multiverse of madness no person no i
would not expect that that'd be crazy
cool mr anderson that's a great point
character development and exposition is
important is important to making
complete narrative yeah i agree i i
think the finale will be more meaningful
after this episode
gucci griffin
normally guide the dead yes that's
actually what her actual god does in
egyptian mythology it is
uh gucci grady did the hippo say
something on the boat that referred to
black panther fires yes she did she
mentioned the ancestral plane
which is the
she she said that you know there are
different planes that you go to after
you die
i wonder what that's based off i i
i want to say that's based off of like
your mind
maybe
um because yeah
that's definitely where you know we've
seen the ancestral plane in the first
black panther film so
uh yes she did uh haiti thanks for
another super chat
jay could have formed whenever he
started enacting violence in conscience
name or from his time as mercenary maybe
formed night he almost died um
you know in the comics jake is a cab
driver and he's the one that gets like
all the information
i wonder if jake is just
i wonder if jake is the person who comes
out
to do the truly
dirty work
when mark doesn't want to that you know
i wonder like kind of like
so you saw stephen when he was watching
mark get manipulated originally and he's
like wow he's been managed believing you
from the beginning
almost like country saw that there was a
split personality disorder
and secretly created his own personality
within that so that he could have total
control at some point yeah it's possible
oh man maybe jake is just conscious
actually kind of punches created pull on
the string a little bit more yeah that
would be nice that'd be kind of cool be
a good spin good way to introduce jake
and make it make sense i think yeah jd
ultra yeah i'd love to see more fights
in the gods and less dialogue for sure
in the finale for sure for sure for sure
for sure hey infinity shades good to see
you good to see you no worries you
haven't been streaming a bit but i'm
glad you're here now thanks for super
chat yeah this was uh got your eyes
tearing up this was a
rough one this was a it was intense and
i actually really liked it yeah i think
layla is going to be uh
uh
layla will probably save kanchi with the
flare because that's what she does she
lights flares and saves people uh
thanks for that super chat man devonte
thanks for super chat i mean the gods
will um oh mark for defeating ahmed thus
getting osiris bring back stephen
also i feel there's room to introduce
jake yeah i just again with like
bringing him back i don't think
i think that's all for mark right i
don't think that gods can bring back a
person that
that isn't truly there like you know
he's not a real
physical person he is just the same
person just an identity inside of him
you know
so i think
he's just going to resurface
right like like almost like a pts
t uh ptsd thing but um
in like a better way like in a good way
so but i like where your head's at
uh daddy bella thanks super chat when
strange and what if destroyed his own
universe what happens to other realms
like the field of reads did you see are
they variants
of the afterlife and dead people they're
probably
different ones for different people and
it's probably one of those things where
it's like it's in your mind you know
what i mean but that's actually a good
question like is there a bunch of
different heavens there are a bunch of
different hells for all the other
variants does heaven and the underworld
do are they
existent inside of a universe right and
then the other universes have their own
that's a good question
maybe multiverse that question probably
will never be answered if i'm gonna be
honest
that's a very big that's a very very
very uh peculiar detail
but i i like i like your your thinking
that's a good question
i think we got
the coolest peephole view
of some of the vibes and tones we're
gonna be getting a doctor stranger the
multiverse of madness
and i just don't think we're ready for
it
i'm ready bring it on i mean i'm pumped
for it but it's gonna be i don't think
we're like
appreciating how how deep they're going
into this kind of like crazy
almost horror-esque vibe and it's gonna
be so much fun yeah the horror stuff i'm
really looking forward to it's gonna be
refreshing as odd as that is to say it's
gonna be refreshing no it's gonna be
cool
carbon outlaw do i think
post credit will be introduced layla's
scarlet scarab well thank you for that
super chat and that would be pretty cool
i did talk about her a lot last time and
clearly that's you know that's
connection through her father and
everything like that so i mean
maybe
uh
uh maybe bra
maybe baby um i don't know
i i try to think of what the post
credits could be and
it's definitely a possibility for sure
they're gonna be moon eyes centric
yeah i just think is it gonna be you
know it's gonna be jake
something with jake or something like
that it'll be jake or it'll be
maybe yeah the like the layla stuff yeah
what's up jason stroup haiti another one
thank you
did
oh that was like w did with uh
dissociative identity disorder there's
protector alters maybe jake's one
yeah
i'm really
i'm really curious about
if they're actually going to show us
jake like i think they did in this
episode at the five minute mark you can
totally hear jake it's a very different
accent
it's almost like uh
like a boston accent yeah i feel like
that's what he would be yeah
uh trent stewart thanks for the super
chat i wonder what tony stark thought
after he saved the entire universe and
woke up to a talking hippopotamus right
or did he have to go through the field
the reeves where they automatically like
you save you know a universe go just
you're good just go through it
that song everyone's been singing that
yeah
austin thank you super chat when do you
guys think we see moon knight after the
short series
hopefully the midnight suns i would
i would love to see that
but i i would really really love to see
it and i hope they do season two i know
it's not confirmed and they keep talking
about how it's just this one-off thing
and all that but i hope they do a season
too
no
it would make sense haiti if jake was
the physical protector
and he kicks in during near-death
situations
kind of like a fine i'll do it myself
moment
all right
hello jesse keiser boop
aj deputy 1024 maybe they'll collect all
five pieces and summon exodia for the
yugioh fans you know what that is if you
don't i'm sorry i missed that on that
left that was a pretty that was a pretty
good one
oh i know enchantrix red i missed steven
that's like why
they really know how to like grab your
heart strings and just
take them
oh yeah heroes playbook for sure
definitely soul stone vibes yeah good to
see here man i know we've uh
chatted on twitter a few times
what's going on
man
the finale's
got a lot of potential
oh yeah a lot of potential not saying
they won't mess it up i hope they know
marvel's pretty good premium
premium package it's it's right there
it's right there to be delivered
uh
esrio
estro jake and other personalities could
still exist the reason losing stephen
balance the scales is because steven and
mark's life started intertwining
i think he still exists
i think he still exists and i think
i think
stephen went or mark gosh that
can't tell you how much i have to think
about that when i do videos like who am
i actually talking about steven
or mark and i was like oh wait i said
mark there and i met stephen right yeah
it's like oh wait that was mr knight not
not moon night ramp
um
i think mark
mark
had to like deal with his past deal with
his trauma i think that's what this
episode was about was about
and stephen right because again i don't
think we can say he's not a real person
he is he had a job he had you know all
the stuff interactions with people that
was that was steven right it was about
steven dealing with trauma
aka
him not actually
being real
not being the original one because he's
like i thought i was original you know
and then and then mark having to deal
with his past and i think once mark
stephen helped mark deal with his past
that was his job but mark or
yeah steven helped mark deal with his
past that was kind of stephen's job
right there that was his job as
as a created identity right to to not
deal with the trauma
to just be happy right but here stephen
had to deal with the trauma and you had
to help mark through it so when stephen
you know got off the boat that it's kind
of like mark
you dealt with it all right you dealt
with it all it wasn't stephen it was you
and now
scale's balanced you dealt with your
past you dealt with your trauma
it's almost like stephen died with the
pain
yeah it's almost like you can leave it
behind now right you can you can
go on a job you know
right and leave lead your own life now
so sergio rodriguez think of super chat
the show is amazing but i just don't
know how they will wrap up the show with
only one episode left also much loved
you guys thank you much love back and
yeah that's what we're talking about you
know it's uh
it's set up exceptionally well
and i you know
i think that it's like you only really
need to tell us a couple things
is it real which i firmly believe yes is
it real right
and how does the how does it end with
ahmed and kanchu and everything do they
summon ahmet and then kanchi was like
dead exactly
go back to b
yeah
go back um but in the future i'd like a
little tease about moon night's future
in the mcu yeah i'd like a little teaser
to post credits or something like that
yeah
um jared page sigma super chat i don't
know if anybody mentioned this but
what if we did see jake what if the mark
they looked all beat up and got injected
into the [ __ ] was jake okay so
uh this hasn't been mentioned in a while
but uh irish
e-rich hey rich i'm so sorry butchering
it mentioned that at the five-minute
mark if you pull up your disney plus
it's pretty crazy you can actually see
jake
i think jake is uh you can actually hear
him
if you go to the five minute mark
do you remember that boy
you think you could tell me about that
little boy
jake also seems to have his mouth
kind of to the side
at the four
four at the 458 mark
you can clearly tell that this is not
stephen or mark and it's gotta be jake
at the 4 58 mark hey thank you i feel
really great
that's a totally different accent
yeah i think yeah yeah totally
mark thanks for super chat tower it was
in a box in turn mark put himself in a
mental box and she found him wildest
twist so far besides kings that you're
showing up look for now
yeah
i mean
it's funny that she said you know i've
never never seen this one but an asylum
before you know uh which is kind of
funny
um
but they're doing a great job of the
series man i mean
this is certainly very different than
any
anything we've seen before i i saw a
couple people ask who jake is
jake lockley in the comics is a third
personality of mark specter there's mark
stephen and jake we
haven't really seen jake yet
but there was that scene in epis
so
three
three or four i can't remember i think
it was three where
you know
there's a bunch of people dead on the
ground and uh mark was like stephen what
did you do and he's like i gotta do this
and mark's like i didn't do this that
was clearly jake
30 39 them scales are balanced let my
boys into the field says a deputy 10 24.
so
yeah haiti marvel really is hitting the
nail on the head with the mental health
it's uh it's crazy huh
i don't you shouldn't have uk accents
it's kind of funny
kaiser kane thanks for that super chat
yeah enchantrex i know i
stephen was real
i'm just gonna keep saying it steven is
real
he's not a separate person but he kind
of is he
he
had a job he interacted with people he
had a horrible boss
he had a we were able to see them
interact with each other yeah that's
cool
i who the heck did he talk to who's his
mom
right
i'm so confused about that well did he
ever talk to her we only ever saw him
leaving messages
well that one where he got up
from the from the funeral
um the shiva
he said it sounded like she was saying
something he would react he's like yeah
yeah i did it again yeah i don't know
maybe he's just nuts i don't know
obviously well no because then there's
the second episode as well or the
first it's the first episode yeah it's
really all blended um the first episode
where
he misses the date and then he calls his
mom after and it sounds like he's having
an actual conversation like oh yeah no
i'm thinking about bringing her around
oh i think maybe mark set him up with
like a fake number and
told the lady he'll pay her to pretend
like he's this kid's mom
maybe
i mean he could have just been talking
to himself and yeah it's probably more
like heard
in his head or something i
oh man
well
let's do it before we get off rate
the episode from an a plus to a plus to
an f minus
what do you rate this episode
and while you're doing it think on the
other episodes compare it to those
episodes let's hear it
what do you guys think
i wanna hear your i wanna i wanna see
what you read it
i think he'd probably be just like
imagining his mom we're growing
um
all right here it comes
uh before we go i'm gonna get the super
chat danny bella thanks for another
super chat if you look at his phone
just a home screen not a call yeah okay
maybe he's just i i did notice that i
was trying to make it out but
brian much gaming i doubt stephen would
turn as much as mark may appreciate him
now i doubt mark will voluntarily bring
stephen back maybe other personalities
though thanks super chat i i think he's
coming back
i do maybe not voluntarily like you said
but maybe involuntarily
uh b a a plus a plus plus a plus c plus
a b plus f minus d minus okay
uh
hahaha super s for u nice
c minus a c minus c minus z dang
a plus
okay okay f i got an f because they
killed stephen other than that b
yep
mercs thanks for super chat last
question uh what if bushman found
apocalypse's armor in that tomb that
what he was after it could be a timeline
where somebody nerd died wouldn't that
be cool though
wouldn't that be super cool i really
like that thought i don't think it would
happen but
i really like that thought thank you
super chat
and apocalypse is oscar isaac's
apocalypse and he's a variant that he
found the
the the
the armor became apocalypse
a lot of a buzzes
look at those months
yep
yeah jam yeah you need to watch it again
it's uh certainly yeah
he's talking about it huh maybe he is
talking to helmet
yeah sue i i know it was this was rough
i
i would rather have lost mark than
i think they knew that
oh of course they knew that's why they
did it everybody loves steven he's such
a gentle soul
i'll throw us off a cliff
well okay
that's what it looks like of
the vast majority of people actually did
really really yeah a lot more people
than i thought i thought a lot of people
might have been lost like lost it on
this episode
but it seems like most people enjoyed a
lot
yeah
let me
look one thing real fast
[Music]
all right i'll have to research that for
the breakdown hippopotamus
oh man you ain't wrong alex wilson oscar
isaac acted the hell out of this episode
give him a
oscar
ah
i'll just give him three
at least two right
especially when you consider he's acting
with himself most of the episode that's
true too actually his brother his real
life brother stood in
oh did he yeah so he was like
interacting
with his real brother nope is dead
dead
uh gucci grady i responded to your super
chat were you not here or did you do
another one that i didn't happen to see
let's take a look up you did
how would you want moon knight to lead
into that strange two and throw four i
think the end of episode six all the
stone guys in the room will be gone yeah
i would like to see them released and
like gore the god butcher had like a
part in killing them and something like
that
um
and i i want to see how they connect
like egyptian gods and greek gods and
north norse gods with like
deities like the living tribunal and
stuff like that you know i'm really
curious to see how
that all kind of ties in so
maybe multiverse madness give it a
little bit
of that but i think thor four
is going to really show us different
gods because gore's going to be killing
gods i think they might show us a little
montage of his life
so
make sure to miss any super chats looks
like i got them all
anime dimension thanks for another super
chat if moon knight is there no steven
then he will explain about the egyptian
gods he will be back i that's true he's
going to need him
he's definitely going to need it
burakus
barakus thompson i give this episode a
but what if that
mom is an easter egg that everyone is
missing i better look we're about to
look i haven't seen this episode in
advance so i haven't dissected it in
advance uh
so we're about to go look
so i'm gonna say let's stop the super
chats guys because we're gonna get off
and they are a little delayed
so i might miss some i don't want to
miss any so let's go ahead and stop the
super chats
but appreciate everyone joining the
stream today appreciate
everyone who watched everyone who typed
everyone super chatted all the new
members super appreciate that and uh
dang um
great episode and
who knows what's gonna happen next i'm
looking forward to a really really great
finale um i actually see doctor strange
on monday at the world premiere me and
chris do so let's go
you're going to ask us questions next
tuesday and we're not going to be able
to answer them
so that'll be something um
yeah that's going to
be so uh
hey sub to the channel if you haven't
yet
i'm gonna have to write like a list of
bullet points of responses and like tape
it here right yeah yes i very much
enjoyed doctor strange and the
multiverse yes doctor strange did have
cameos
yes it was
a movie
yeah
pretty much it was everybody else wants
to butter it up i would give a speech of
facts yeah
there's only one god ma'am and i'm
pretty sure he doesn't dress like that
look at you deputy coming up with all
the quotes um
be sure to sub to chris's channel and
also mr anderson also has a channel
himself the awesome mod that you see
here doing a bunch of work today so be
sure to subscribe to him too and uh you
can subscribe to me if you want i guess
i post sometimes
do it oh heidi gotcha i got you heidi
sorry
i see you hate it let's see though i see
the y i definitely want to say
yeah that's my bet got you heidi though
i got you i will remember i will
remember uh
i wish i could get some rest mr anderson
but we're gonna we're gonna just work so
i'm gonna be up for at least four more
hours probably it's gonna be a long
enough this is gonna be a long night so
we didn't foresee this one i didn't see
this episode in advance so
yeah
much love enchantrex you have a great
night as well
um and soon late as gate does hit me up
on instagram please i will see everybody
uh the next live stream um after i see
multiverse madness that's gonna be
it's gonna be pretty crazy so anyways
love you all we'll see you next time